you did a
concert for the BBC and I think it was
71.
and it's great but you said something
off the cuff there's a there's a it's
terrific you can you can see it and I
think it's part of the Harvest 50th uh
um catalog
but it's just you just say it off but it
struck me because it's very you you're
playing these songs that are all going
to become Classics but this audience
hasn't heard them before yeah and you're
in London and you're playing and they're
a nice crowd but at one point
you say how y'all doing and they go they
don't go
they you know they go like yeah yeah
good you know good they're polite
English people listening to new songs
from this man and they're like yeah yeah
it's good you know good and you went
yeah yeah I can tell that you you're
sensing that they're fine but they're
not and you go yeah yeah well must be
that they're new songs and then you say
but
that's what's happening and I love that
because that really and then you're
trying to be funny you just say yeah but
that's what's happening and then you
proceed to you know play a song that
will become a classic but they don't
know it yet and what struck me about
that is that
to me that's
the philosophy you have to have whether
it's in music or comedy which is your
job is not to try and figure out what
they want and make them happy you've got
to do what you're going to do
that's and this is what's happening yeah
and then uh
uh on the on on the new record on world
record there's a clip of you and
someone in your someone is talking to
you I don't know if it's Rick Rubin or
someone's talking to you and says man
this one you got a lyric here about
every you know I take every breath and I
feel like I'm doing a dance a dance with
death it's about covid and and he says
man that's really dark and you you go
[ __ ] them they don't have to buy it
and I was like that has to be the way it
is you know what I mean that has to be
you're echoing what you're saying in 71
in London now with world record uh
you're saying
um I think that song is break the chain
you're saying
uh I'm driving this bus you might not
like where we're going you're welcome to
get off if you don't like where we're
going and I believe in that philosophy I
think that's the way it has to be if
you're trying to be it sounds
highfalutin but if you're trying to be
an artist that's what you have to do
yeah it's easy I mean if as long as you
do that and then you feel good about it
too no matter what you're doing you feel
good about it because you're doing it
the way you want to do it right
and uh that's a good thing yeah it's
good and it feels like you've had times
too where
you you've had this enormous success and
people really love the music and then
there's part of you that's like how do I
how do I crank the wheel here and get
them off my trail bro I really gotta all
right you you followed me this far I'm
gonna go I'm going to take this thing
this old jalopy up the side of this
muddy Hill right and uh challenge them a
little bit Yeah well every once in a
while they they all go the other way
yeah and that's a that's a good thing
you like that that's fine yeah because
they you know it's just that I went
somewhere I'll come back probably yeah
doesn't matter the thing is did we do
what we wanted to do yes because that's
what we're supposed to be doing yes yeah
you know we don't want to do what they
want us to do that's not what they're
looking for really right right you know
no they don't know what they want they
that's the other thing so I I think
that's kind of the magic of it